[Music]  [Music]  that  for brainwashed girl how do you know she  doesn't really agree with them  they snatched her from her own home at  gunpoint  it's hard hiding who i am holding my  tongue  i don't know how much longer i can stand  it  i never wanted to be in this alone  [Applause]  how long you've been underground a  couple years you make bombs  i used to they murdered our comrades  this is a war we got to survive just  like we do  it isn't there right princess don't talk  to her like that  how long were you in a closet was it a  closet he will kill me if you leave  this this is over  get in the car get in the car  i never took you for an outlaw  you ready i wish you'd say one thing as  long as it's true  you can't just sit around waiting to die  or be caught  it's the only way you're going to  survive underground  [Music]  you